Today I'll show you how to configure a Google Cloud Platform Project for Zync.
Start on the Cloud Console project management page.
Click Create Project to make a new project to use with Zync.
Be sure to note the project ID.
Navigate to billing and ensure that billing is turned on.
Now navigate to the API Manager and enable to the
Compute Engine and Zync Render APIs.
Now navigate to zyncrender.com and click Register.
Put in your Google Cloud Platform Project ID.
Choose your site name and put in the company name.
Now your registration is complete.
You will recieve an email with further instructions shortly.
Please check out some of our other Cloud Minute videos.